un ensemble de valeurs de gauche progressives qui disent :
« Baissez le pont-levis ! Le monde est génial.
Les gens en Syrie souffrent -- nous devons les accueillir. »
C'est très beau.
J'étais en Suède cet été,
si le discours en Suède est plutôt politiquement correct
et qu'ils ne parlent pas des inconvénients,
on finit par faire venir beaucoup de gens.
Cela va diminuer le capital social,
il sera difficile d'avoir un état providence
et ils finiront peut-être, comme nous en Amérique,
avec une société racialement divisée, visiblement racialement divisée.
Il est très difficile d'en parler.
Mais je crois qu'il faut considérer cela, en Europe et aussi en Amérique.
CA : Vous dites que les gens de raison,
les gens ne se considérant pas racistes
mais moraux, honnêtes,
ont une logique qui dit que les humains sont trop différents ;
qu'il y a un risque de surcharge
de notre perception de ce dont les gens sont capables,
en mélangeant des gens qui sont trop différents.
JH : Oui, mais je peux rendre cela encore plus acceptable
en disant qu'il n'est pas nécessairement question de race.
Il s'agit de la culture.
Il y a un travail génial d'une politologue, Karen Stenner,
qui montre que lorsque les gens ont l'impression
que nous sommes tous unis, tous les mêmes,
beaucoup ont une prédisposition pour l'autoritarisme.
Ces gens ne sont pas particulièrement racistes
quand ils ont l'impression que notre ordre social et moral n'est pas en danger.
Si vous leur faites penser expérimentalement
que nous nous divisons, que les gens deviennent différents,
ils deviennent plus racistes, homophobes, veulent expulser les déviants.
Vous avez donc en partie une réaction autoritaire.
La gauche, suivant phrase lennoniste --
la phrase de John Lennon --
fait des choses qui créent une réaction autoritaire.
Nous le voyons aux États-Unis, avec l'extrême-droite.
Nous le voyons en Grande-Bretagne, à travers l'Europe.
Mais le côté de plus positif
est que je pense que les localistes ou les nationalistes ont raison --
en valorisant notre similarité culturelle,
la race n'a plus beaucoup d'importance.
Une approche assimilationniste de l'immigration
supprime nombre de ces problèmes.
Si un État-providence généreux est important,
il faut mettre en avant que nous sommes tous les mêmes.
CA : L'augmentation de l'immigration et des peurs qui y sont liées
est l'une des causes de la division actuelle.
Quelles sont les autres causes ?
JH : Le principe de psychologie morale suivant
est que les intuitions viennent avant le raisonnement stratégique.
Vous avez dû entendre parler de « raisonnement motivé »,
de « préjugé de confirmation ».
Il y a des travaux très intéressants
sur comment notre haute intelligence et nos capacités verbales
pourraient avoir évolué, pas pour nous aider à trouver la vérité
mais à manipuler les autres, défendre notre réputation...
Nous savons très, très bien nous justifier.
En prenant en compte les intérêts du groupe,
il ne s'agit pas de moi mais de mon équipe contre la vôtre,
même en considérant des éléments prouvant que votre côté a tort,
vous ne pouvez pas l'accepter.
Voila pourquoi vous ne pouvez pas gagner un débat politique.
Lors d'un débat,
il est impossible de persuader par la logique et des preuves
car nous ne raisonnons pas ainsi.
Donnez-nous internet, donnez-nous Google :
« On m'a dit que Barack Obama est né au Kenya.
Je vais chercher sur Google -- mon dieu, 10 millions de clics, c'est vrai ! »
CA : Cela est une surprise déplaisante pour beaucoup de gens.
Les techno-optimistes ont souvent dit des médias sociaux
que c'était une grande force de liaison qui réunirait les gens.
Il y a eu des effets secondaires inattendus.
JH : C'est exact.
J'aime beaucoup la comparaison
entre le ying-yang de la nature humaine et la gauche-droite -
chaque côté a raison sur certains points
mais est aveugle sur d'autres.
En général, la gauche croit en la bonté de la nature humaine :
réunir les gens, faire tomber les murs et tout ira bien.
La droite -- les conservateurs sociaux, pas les libertaires --
en général, les conservateurs sociaux croient que les gens sont cupides,
sexuels et égoïstes,
il nous faut des lois et des restrictions.
Si vous faites tomber les murs,
permettez aux gens de communiquer à travers le monde,
il y a beaucoup de porno et de racisme.
CA : Aidez-nous à comprendre.
Ces principes de la nature humaine ont toujours existé.
Qu'est-ce qui a changé et renforcé ce sentiment de division ?
JH : Il faut y voir six à dix choses différentes qui convergent.
Je vais en lister quelques-unes.
En Amérique -- en Amérique et en Europe -- une des choses importantes
est la seconde guerre mondiale.
Joe Henrich a participé à une recherche intéressante
qui dit que si votre pays était en guerre,
surtout quand vous étiez jeune,
et que l'on vous teste 30 ans plus tard
dans un dilemme des communs ou du prisonnier,
vous serez plus coopératif.
A cause de votre nature tribale, si vous êtes --
mes parents étaient adolescents pendant la guerre
et ils allaient chercher des bouts d'aluminium
pour l'effort de guerre.
Tout le monde s'entraidait.
Ces gens vont de l'avant,
ils progressent grâce au commerce et au gouvernement,
ils deviennent dirigeants.
Ils savent bien faire des compromis et coopérer.
Ils sont partis à la retraite dans les années 90.
A la fin des années 90, il nous reste les baby boomers.
Leur enfance a été passée à se battre entre eux
à partir de 1968.
La perte de la génération de la guerre, « la génération grandiose »,
est énorme.
Voilà une des causes.
Une autre, en Amérique, est la purification des deux partis.
Il y avait des républicains libéraux, des démocrates conservateurs.
Au milieu du XXe siècle, l'Amérique était bipartite.
Mais du fait d'une variété de facteurs qui ont fait bouger les choses,
d'ici aux années 90, les partis libéral et conservateur étaient purifiés.
Aujourd'hui, les gens des deux partis sont différents
et nous ne voulons pas que nos enfants les épousent,
ce qui, dans les années 60, n'importait pas.
La purification des partis.
La troisième chose, c'est internet, comme je l'ai dit,
c'est le meilleur stimulant pour raisonner et démoniser après coup.
CA : Le ton de ce qu'il se passe sur internet est assez inquiétant.
J'ai fait une recherche rapide sur l'élection sur Twitter
et j'ai vu deux tweets côte à côte.
L'un, à côté d'une photo d'un graffiti raciste :
« C'est dégoûtant !
La laideur dans ce pays, apportée par #Trump. »
Et le suivant c'était :
« La page de dédicace à Hillary la malhonnête. Dégoûtant ! »
Cette idée de « dégoût » m'inquiète.
Car quand vous vous disputez ou êtes en désaccord avec quelqu'un,
vous pouvez vous énerver.
Le dégoût, vous ai-je entendu dire, amènent les choses à un autre niveau.
JH : Exact, le dégoût est différent.
La colère -- j'ai des enfants.
Ils se battent 10 fois par jour
et s'aiment 30 fois par jour.
C'est un va-et-vient, vous êtes : énervé, pas énervé,
énervé, pas énervé.
Le dégoût est différent.
Le dégoût dépeint la personne comme inhumaine, monstrueuse,
déformée, déformée moralement.
Le dégoût est une encre indélébile.
John Gottman a fait une recherche sur la thérapie de couple.
Si vous regardez les visages -- si l'un révèle du dégoût ou du mépris,
cela permet de prédire qu'ils vont bientôt divorcer,
alors que s'ils révèlent de la colère, cela ne prédit rien,
car si vous gérez bien la colère, elle peut être bonne.
Cette élection est différente.
Donald Trump lui-même utilise beaucoup le mot « dégoût ».
Il est très sensible aux germes, le dégoût lui importe --
plus pour lui, c'est quelque chose qui lui est unique --
mais alors que nous démonisons encore plus l'autre,
à nouveau, à travers la vision manichéenne du monde,
l'idée que le monde est un combat entre le bien et le mal,
une vision prépondérante,
nous ne dirons pas qu'ils ont tort ou que nous ne les aimons pas,
nous dirons qu'ils sont démoniaques, sataniques,
dégoûtants, révoltants.
Et nous ne voulons rien avoir à faire avec eux.
A mon avis, cela explique pourquoi nous voyons cela sur des campus,
l'urgence de tenir les gens éloignés du campus,
les faire taire, les garder à distance.
J'ai peur que toute cette génération de jeunes gens,
si leur introduction à la politique comporte beaucoup de dégoût,
ils ne voudront pas être impliqués dans la politique en vieillissant.
CA : Comment gérer cela ?
Le dégoût. Comment apaiser le dégoût ?
JH : Pas avec la raison.
Je pense...
J'ai étudié le dégoût durant des années, je pense souvent aux émotions.
Je pense que l'opposé du dégoût est l'amour.
En amour, il est question de...
Le dégoût, c'est fermer les frontières.
L'amour, c'est dissoudre les murs.
Les relations personnelles, je pense,
sont probablement le moyen le plus puissant que nous ayons.
Vous pouvez être dégoûté par un groupe de personnes
puis vous rencontrez quelqu'un
et vous découvrez qu'il est adorable.
Progressivement, votre catégorisation s'écaille ou change également.
La tragédie, c'est que les Américains se mélangeaient plus dans leurs villes
selon la gauche-droite, la politique.
Cela est devenu une grande division morale,
il y a des preuves que nous déménagions pour être proches des gens
nous ressemblant politiquement.
Il est plus dur de trouver quelqu'un de l'autre parti.
Soit ils sont par ici, soit ils sont loin.
Il est plus dur de les connaître.
CA : Que diriez-vous à quelqu'un ou aux Américains,
aux gens en général,
quant à ce que nous devrions comprendre de l'autre
qui nous aiderait à repenser
cet instinct de « dégoût » ?
JH : Oui.
Une chose importante dont il faut se souvenir,
il y a des recherches du politologue Alan Abramowitz
qui montrent que la démocratie américaine est de plus en plus gouvernée
par ce qui s'appelle la « partisanerie négative ».
Vous pensez qu'il y a un candidat,
que vous aimez le candidat, vous votez pour lui.
Mais avec la montée de la publicité négative,
les médias sociaux et d'autres modes,
de plus en plus, les élections sont faites
pour que le parti adverse semble horrible, atroce
et ainsi vous voterez par défaut pour le candidat.
De plus en plus, nous votons contre l'autre parti
plutôt que pour notre parti.
Nous devons nous souvenir que si les gens sont à gauche,
ils pensent : « Je pensais que les républicains étaient mauvais
et Donald Trump le prouve.
Je peux dépeindre tous les républicains grâce aux choses
que je pense de Trump. »
Ce n'est pas forcément vrai.
En général, ils ne sont pas contents de leur candidat.
C'est l'élection avec le plus de partisanerie négative
de l'histoire américaine.
Il faut d'abord séparer vos sentiments envers le candidat
de vos sentiments envers les gens qui ont un choix.
Puis vous devez réaliser que,
car nous vivons dans un monde moral différent --
dans mon livre, la métaphore est que nous sommes dans « la Matrice »
ou que chaque communauté morale
est une matrice, une hallucination consensuelle.
Si vous êtes dans la matrice bleue,
tout vous prouve que l'autre camp --
ce sont des troglodytes, des racistes, les pires personnes du monde
et tous les faits le soutiennent.
Mais quelqu'un dans la maison voisine à la vôtre
vit dans une matrice morale différente.
Ils vivent dans un jeu vidéo différent
et ils voient des faits complètement différents.
Chacun voit des menaces différentes envers le pays.
Ce que j'ai découvert en étant au milieu,
en essayant de comprendre les deux camps : les deux ont raison.
Il y a beaucoup de menaces envers le pays
et chaque camp est, par constitution, incapable de toutes les voir.
CA : Vous dites donc qu'il nous faut presque un nouveau genre d'empathie ?
La définition traditionnelle de l'empathie est :
« Je ressens ta douleur. Je peux me mettre à ta place. »
Nous l'appliquons à ceux qui sont pauvres, dans le besoin, souffrants.
En général, nous ne l'appliquons pas à ceux qui semblent différents
ou qui nous dégoûtent.
JH : Non, c'est exact.
CA : Comment pourrions-nous bâtir cette nouvelle empathie ?
JH : En fait, je pense...
L'empathie est un sujet très actuel en psychologie
et c'est un mot populaire surtout à gauche.
L'empathie est une bonne chose, l'empathie pour les classes de victimes préférées.
Il faut avoir de l'empathie
pour les groupes que nous, à gauche, pensons importants.
C'est facile à faire car vous gagnez des points.
Mais vous devriez gagner des points pour ce qui est difficile à faire.
Et je pense...
Nous avons eu une période de 50 ans où nous avons réglé les problèmes de race
et la discrimination légale.
Pendant longtemps, cela était notre priorité
et c'est encore important.
Mais je pense que cette année,
j'espère que cela montrera aux gens
que nous avons une menace existentielle devant nous.
Je crois que notre division gauche-droite
est de loin la division la plus importante.
Nous avons encore des problèmes de race, de genre, LGBT,
mais c'est le besoin urgent au cours des 50 prochaines années
et les choses ne vont pas s'améliorer d'elles-mêmes.
Il va falloir faire beaucoup de réformes institutionnelles
et nous pourrions en parler
mais c'est toute une longue et étrange conversation.
Je pense que cela commence avec les gens qui comprennent ce moment décisif.
Oui, nous avons besoin d'une nouvelle empathie.
Nous devons réaliser que c'est ce dont le pays a besoin
et dont vous avez besoin si vous ne voulez pas --
levez la main si vous voulez passer les 4 années à venir
autant en colère et inquiet que cette année, levez la main.
Si vous voulez échapper à cela,
lisez Bouddha, Jésus et Marc Aurèle.
Ils ont tous de bons conseils sur comment abandonner la peur,
recadrer les choses,
ne plus voir les autres comme vos ennemis.
La sagesse ancienne est pleine de conseils pour cette empathie.
CA : Ma dernière question :
personnellement, qu'est-ce que les gens peuvent faire pour guérir ?
JH : Il est très dur de décider de vaincre vos préjugés les plus profonds.
Des recherches montrent
que les préjugés politiques sont plus profonds et forts que les préjugés raciaux
actuellement dans le pays.
Je pense que vous devez faire un effort, c'est cela qui importe.
Faites l'effort de rencontrer quelqu'un.
Tout le monde a un cousin, un beau-frère,
quelqu'un de l'autre camp.
Après cette élection --
attendez deux semaines
car cela va sembler horrible à l'un d'entre vous --
attendez deux semaines puis dites que vous voulez parler.
Avant de le faire,
lisez « Comment se faire des amis » de Dale Carnegie.
(Rires)
Je suis très sérieux.
Vous apprendrez des techniques si vous admettez,
si vous dites :
« Nous ne sommes pas beaucoup d'accord
mais une chose que je respecte chez toi, oncle Bob »
ou « chez vous, conservateurs, est... »
Vous pouvez trouver une chose.
Commencer avec de l'estime, c'est magique.
C'est l'une des choses que j'ai apprises
et que j'applique à mes relations.
Je fais toujours plein d'erreurs idiotes
mais maintenant je sais bien m'excuser
et reconnaître quand quelqu'un a raison sur un point.
Si vous faites cela,
la conversation se passe bien et est très amusante.
CA : Parler avec vous est fascinant.
On dirait que le sol sur lequel nous nous tenons
est un sol peuplé de questions profondes sur la moralité et la nature humaine.
Votre sagesse ne pourrait pas être plus adéquate.
Merci d'avoir partagé ce moment avec nous.
JH : Merci Chris.
JH : Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)